Great. So
first, I'd like to thank all of you for exploring the
bowels of the San Diego Convention Center with me
and with my colleagues here on the
stage. I understand that King Tut
is actually next door,
and it was originally discovered there, so keep your eyes out for other interesting
discoveries.
No, but thank you very much to the meeting organizers and the scientific
committees for including this session in this year's very
exciting, very interesting meeting.
The title of the session is "Advances in Hemologic Malignancies:
Population Sciences for Hematological Malignancies."
So genetically, as we all know, all humans are very
similar but not identical in our genetic makeup,
and much of this variation that distinguishes us is the
result of differences in ancestry.
While most variants are evolutionarily neutral, it's well known
that genetic variation can be associated with differences
in wellness and illness.
In this population sciences session, we're going to spotlight
genetic ancestry as one factor that is associated with
differences in the etiology and outcomes of hematologic
malignancies among diverse populations, and
we will also consider how genetic studies that incorporate
individuals of diverse ancestries are helping to explain
the observed clinical differences.
In our first talk, I'm going to discuss diversity writ large
and its influence on genetic studies.
I'm also going to discuss how we at Roswell Park Comprehensive Cancer
Center are building the infrastructure to facilitate future
studies of diversity in cancer.
Then Dr. Anne Katherine Eisfeldt from the Ohio State
University will present her work on genetic studies
leveraging diversity to understand the biology and
outcomes in AML. Then finally, Dr.
Nick Panunzio from UC Irvine is going to discuss his work on
genetics and ALL in Hispanics.
If there's time after all of us have presented, we will open the
floor to a general discussion.
On behalf of all of us here on the bimah,
I hope that you enjoy the session. So thanks very much, and let's get
started. Okay. May we have the first slide
presentation?
All right. So thank you. So again,
I'm Ken Onel. I'm from Roswell Park, and I'm going to be talking
about work that we've been doing at Roswell Park to enable these genetic
studies.
So I have no conflicts to disclose, sadly.
Please feel free to change that after the meeting.
Let's start by thinking about polymorphic variations.
So this is a map of the world from
the Thousand Genomes Project from Goncalo Abecasis'
paper.
And what we see is that if we look at the gray boxes,
we see that most polymorphic variation is
common across multiple populations.
But in the colored boxes, what we see is that there are
considerable polymorphic variation that is
unique to different populations.
The consequence of this, of course, is that there
may be population-based differences in
wellness and illness. And of course, this is well known to be the case.
So now if we look at population diversity in a different
way using linkage disequilibrium, we see
again differences among populations.
So here are three regions of the genome that were
genotyped in 12 different populations.
And what we can see is that this is now looking at
patterns of linkage disequilibrium or correlations among
variants
as a function of space in the genome.
And what we see is that in newer populations, there are large
regions of the genome that travel together,
whereas in older populations such as African
populations, those regions of
linkage disequilibrium break down, and the linkage blocks are
considerably different and smaller.
A consequence of this difference in linkage
disequilibrium is patterns of LD
across regions in different populations.
So here is a single region that has been
characterized in first European ancestry individuals
and then two different African admixed populations.
And what we see is that while the variants in this
region in Europeans are highly correlated with each other,
that pattern of correlation breaks
down and is quite different in
Afro-German and Afro-Caribbean populations.
So we took advantage of these differences in
LD to perform a multiethnic
genome-wide association study in pediatric B-lineage ALL.
We did our discovery and our replication in European ancestry
individuals, and we identified a novel association at
chromosome 9.21.3.
Then if we look across the region, we see that in
individuals of European ancestry, our discovery and replication
sets and Hispanic ancestry, the
region isHighly correlated. These
SNPs in the region are highly correlated
with each other with an R squared of greater than 0.6.
That LD structure breaks down in African
ancestry individuals. So what we did was we
genotyped these variants in all three
ancestry individuals and performed a regional association study.
And what we saw is that in African individuals, the only SNP that was
associated was a different SNP,
RS662463. And so if you look at the
region, what you see is that in Europeans and
in Hispanic individuals, this SNP
and the lead SNP comprise a single
highly correlated region, whereas in African ancestry
individuals, that correlation, that haplotype structure,
breaks down. And so what we were able to do then is by taking
advantage of these differences in LD across populations, go
from a tagging SNP identified in European individuals to a
putative functional SNP identified in African ancestry
individuals. And then in the study, we went along to
demonstrate that in fact this variant is the true
functional risk allele predisposing to B lineage ALL
by disrupting a transcription finder binding site for
CEBPB that ultimately resulted in lower levels
of CD and TB binding. Expression rather.
So that's one example of how we use differences in
ancestry to go from tags to functional variants in
genetic studies. But I want to turn back to where we started,
which is thinking about differences, variation
in ancestry, and how that might relate to
differences in cancer etiology,
architecture, and outcomes. So if we think about the
genetics of different populations as being slightly different,
those differences in variation may have implications
for cancer phenotypes. And in fact, it turns out that this
is, of course, true.
And we're going to hear more about this over the course of the remainder of the
session.
So here in heme malignancies are studies showing that
genetic ancestry is associated with survival
in T lineage ALL. Here's another study
in childhood acute lymphoblastic anemia, again showing that
ancestry is associated with differences in molecular subtypes.
And here from MSK is a study showing that ancestry is
associated with the genomic architecture, the
landscape of cancers across essentially all cancer
types. So indeed, ancestry influences cancer
phenotypes.
But I want us to think about this in a little bit more nuanced of a
way. So to be sure, variation in
genetic ancestry will influence cancer phenotypes,
but cancer is a complex trait resulting from the actions and the
interactions of genetic factors and non-genetic factors.
And so if we think about variation in
environment exposures.
If we think about
individuals who are or are not exposed to different
etiologic cancer-causing exposures, smoking, differences in
diet, chemicals, radiation.
Yes or no. Those exposures will activate different
pathways. And if there's heterogeneity in the pathways
and heterogeneity in our exposure, the inevitable consequence
of this morass of heterogeneity and
diversity is that we're going to attenuate our overall
genetic signals.
So
the point then is that diversity in genetic studies,
to be sure, includes
genetic diversity and ancestry, but it's a whole lot more.
So race, ethnicity, sex, gender, social economic
status,
social determinants of health, rural, urban environments.
Completely different sets of exposures, of course.
Exposure to smoking or alcohol, diet, nutrition,
obesity, infections, and so on and so forth.
So the point is that there's a lot of diversity that is
not reflected exclusively in the context of
ancestry, but that clearly acts and interacts
with core differences in diversity to result in
diversity in tumor etiology, tumor architecture, and mutation
signatures, and of course, clinical outcomes.
So let's think of an example to sort of make that
case. So Hodgkin lymphoma. Here's a study that was
performed by Wendy Cozen and Tom Mack looking at
pairs of MZ and DZ twins. And what they found
is that the concordance of the developing of
Hodgkin lymphoma in MZ twins was markedly higher
than in DZ twins. Since that's controlling for environment, the
conclusion is that Hodgkin lymphoma is a highly
genetically determined trait. Here, though, in
a later study from 2009 by Wendy and Tom again,
what we see is that in twins that are
discordant for Hodgkin's phenotype,
then we see differences in exposures,
specifically fecal-oral exposures, suggesting...
And the significance is quite profound
with an odds ratio that is lowered by half.
So the point is that even highly genetically determined traits are
highly modified by non-genetic factors.
And so we really need to think about these two
sources of diversity in
concertSo really,
I think one of the only studies that attempted to control for
diversity in ancestry and diversity in exposure
was one that we did a few years ago, looking at second cancer,
again, after Hodgkin lymphoma, in which we tried to control for both
genetic and non-genetic diversity.
The idea is that Hodgkin lymphoma is highly associated with
exposure to radiation to the chest.
The second cancers that we see are largely breast cancers and
thyroid cancers.
The occurrence of these radiation-induced second cancers is inversely
correlated with age. So if you're treated for Hodgkin lymphoma under age
20, you're very high risk for these radiation-induced second cancers.
Over 20, you're at a much lower risk.
The point is that this is also a very important clinical phenotype, and it's
responsible for about 20% of mortality in Hodgkin
lymphoma survivors. So it's profound.
Now, the key point of the study is by virtue of
controlling for both exposure and ancestry,
we were able to do a well-powered study with a very limited
number of cases and controls. So just 96 cases and
82 controls. This was done in collaboration with a childhood
cancer survivor study. We identified
two regions that were associated
with these radiation-induced second cancers.
We performed a replication analysis, and we were able to replicate
the findings on chromosome 6. It turns out
that the region was intragenic between a gene called
ATG5, which
functions in autophagy, and a gene called PRDM1, which is
also known as BLIMP1, which is a transcriptional repressor
that is often mutated, actually somatically, in non-Hodgkin's
lymphoma. We then performed functional studies with cell
lines that were either homozygous for the protective
variant or homozygous for the risk variant.
And you can see here western blots following radiation
exposure, and this is reflected as well in these
graphs, that there's both significantly increased baseline
levels of PRDM1 following
in cells that were homozygous for the protective
allele as compared to the risk allele.
And again, in cells homozygous for the protective allele,
there was significant induction following radiation exposure.
So the point is that we were able to start with a
well-controlled experiment, a very small number of cases and controls,
and then go to function that was
associated with this
phenotype.
And really underscoring how important this result is,
if we look at individuals who are homozygous
for the protective allele by
20 years after exposure to radiation, only about
3% had been diagnosed with some of these
radiation-induced second cancers, whereas individuals who are homozygous
for the risk allele, it's 30%. So that is an incredibly
profound difference resulting from one
variant that lives at the intersection of
genes and environment. So
I really like this example because it really underscores how important this
is. So
with this as a framework, what I want to do is
really spend our last few minutes telling you how we at Roswell Park
are leveraging clinical care to prepare the
infrastructure for future studies that integrate diversity
and enable genomic research in human malignancies.
So this is just a study. These are
just numbers that show diversity in Buffalo and the
Buffalo metropolitan area. So Buffalo itself is a city of
about 250,000 individuals. It's
35% Black or African American
and
12, almost 13% Hispanic. If, however,
we widen to the Buffalo metropolitan area, this
racial and ethnic diversity goes away.
We go from 35% Black to 12%
Black, and
from 12% Hispanic to 6% Hispanic.
If we then look beyond the Buffalo metropolitan area to all
of Western New York, it gets even more
monotonous.
83% white, only 9.5%
Black, and
I don't see Hispanic
here,
but I'm sure it's here somewhere. Oh, here it is.
And 5.7% Hispanic. So the point is that we have
very limited racial and ethnic diversity in Buffalo.
But if you look at our catchment area, what you see
is that we are actually quite diverse in terms of our geography.
So we have urban, suburban areas surrounding Roswell
Park, but then the other counties are
either rural or Appalachian, or we have
Native Americanum,
territories in our area as well. So
what that means is that the exposure milieu
of our
patients and of our families are
quite diverse, right? And if we think about
specific health-associated behaviors, what we see
is that, again, across the counties of our catchment area, there
is considerable
exposure to risk behaviors that can be
integrated into genetic studies of diversity.
Specifically thinking about AML, we of course, are very
fortunate in that we have more Superfund sites than
anywhere in the country. Love Canal is part of our area.
And then, of course, the West Valley Demonstration Project that
is basically nothing but nuclear waste that's located just 35
miles away from Buffalo. When we think
about exposures in New York and we think about
urban, rural, ionizing radiation and the factories, right?
Ionizing radiation, benzene, ethylene oxide, pesticides, and of
course, smoking. So we are quite diverse in terms of our
exposure heterogeneity.
So what is our aspiration?
We are in the process of building out a clinical genomic data
commons to drive clinical care and research.
The idea is that we're in the process of
implementing routine clinical germline and tumor sequencing for all
patients. We have universal consent to facilitate research.
We're collecting germline and serial tumor samples linked to
clinical data, and then we're building out an integrated data commons
with genomic data, clinical data, and that's highly
searchable. And then through the new Department of
Clinical Genomics, which is our cancer risk program, we're also building
out a unique high-risk prospective cohort.
So let's talk about these in a little bit more detail.
So first, the universal consent. We collect and we are asking
for permission for demographic data, clinical and treatment data,
sample collection,
the right to do genomics, and really importantly, the
right to recontact or to identify
our consented research participants based on study
IRBs. And right now, so far, we have an 80% plus
accrual rate, so it's successful.
We have a really amazing biorepository
that collects serial samples and lifestyle and risk
factors.
Then we have a really unique informatics
resource and of course, the Department of Clinical Genomics that we've already
mentioned. So just to highlight the biorepository, it
actually is comprised of three legacy biobanks.
It was launched in April of 2024. If we think about
numbers, this is where it gets really exciting.
1.3 million blood, bone marrow, and other sample types from
over 50,000 patients and 4,000 controls.
Specifically thinking about heme malignancies, 3,900 leukemia
patients, 1,220 myeloma patients, and 3,050
lymphoma patients with over 220,000 bone marrow and blood
samples from heme malignancy patients.
So it's an astonishing research to facilitate research.
So if we think about the clinical data commons that we've built out,
we have a data commons that with harmonized demographic and
clinical data, with standardized data dictionaries,
definitions. We have an open-source tool, something called
Insight, that allows for really complicated and
nuanced searches of the database to identify
individuals for cohorts, for studies.
And so through Insight, we bring together
clinical registry, biospecimen, and research data
into a single searchable source. It's of course
OMOP model-based, and it's
designed to be secure. So here's just a very quick
example, something that I did in five minutes, shortly before
this session, just to show you the power and the use of Insight.
So I was just interested in asking about the
use of genetic testing in our AML patients.
So I did a quick search asking who's
had genetic testing. There were
523 individuals. I then asked
of AML patients who's not had genetic testing, and that's
1,195 individuals. So these are just the
demographics of individuals who have not had
genetic testing, and you see it includes sex,
ethnicity, whether they were treated at Roswell, alcohol,
tobacco, and so on. So we get a lot of information about
both their numbers and breakdown
in terms of potential diversity.
This now looks specifically at the
523 individuals who have had genetic testing.
And here we see the top mutations that are identified in
these patients and the top genes that have been mutated in these patients, and
this is just a five-minute search.
So then finally, I just asked Kaplan-Meier survival, and what we
see is that here in European ancestry
individuals, which are the blue and the green lines, there is in fact a significant
difference in outcomes as a function of genetic testing.
The numbers, as you see over here, the y-axis in
this graph, which is just trends over
time,
the numbers of African ancestry, African Americans, is very,
very low.
But what you see is that over time,
in individuals of European ancestry, white people,
theThere's a significant and prolonged
drop
in individuals who have not had genetic testing and a significant
increase in individuals who have had genetic testing.
If we look in individuals of African ancestry, again,
the total count is very low, as is not
surprising given our catchment area.
But what you see is that starting in
2023, so later than what we see
in white people, everyone who is African
ancestry did have genetic testing.
So we can see trends, we can identify disparities,
we can use this information to guide both clinical
care and research. So finally, in the last couple
seconds,
I want to just introduce you to the Department of Clinical Genomics,
which is, again, our cancer risk program.
So what's different about clinical genomics at Roswell is
that, yes, of course, we have a counseling service that's dedicated
to getting people tested, but we also have a medicine service
that follows, longitudinally, individuals who are at high
risk once they've been diagnosed.
So we see them regularly, and we see them over time.
And what that means is that by virtue of this longitudinal
follow-up, we can repurpose the clinical program
into a prospective high-risk cohort,
for research purposes, and really ask about the overlay
of exposures on top of genetics over time as they
happen in a way that minimizes the well-known biases.
So clinically, conceptually, the idea of the department is
that it's a medical home dedicated to prevention and wellness
for these
high-risk individuals.
And one thing that I think is actually really important is that
we are not reliant upon individuals coming to genetics
for genetic testing. We've empowered our colleagues throughout the
institute, including heme malignancies, to perform genetic
testing right then and there, and to consent
the patients right then and there for future research.
So it's a really powerful system that,
the way that I think of it is that it prevents thinking, and that's
important if we're going to integrate these
research practices into routine care.
So
my time is just about up, so I'll conclude.
So what have we covered in this talk?
So first, ancestry-based genetic diversity contributes, of course,
to observed differences in etiology and outcomes in heme
malignancies and, of course, other cancers.
But importantly, we can't forget about non-genetic factors,
non-genetic exposures, and diversity that also contribute to
differences in etiology and outcomes in heme malignancies and other
cancers. So we have to think about
the fact that these two arms of
the complex trait
landscape don't function in isolation,
but in fact act and interact with each other and have to be
considered together as modifiers of each other's
effect. Right? So incorporating diversity
into genetic studies in heme malignancies and other cancers has to
be thought about as more than just incorporating ancestry, although, of course,
ancestry is a necessary component.
So at Roswell, I've sort of showed you how we're building the
infrastructure to facilitate future genetic
research in heme malignancies,
and hopefully it's something that might be a model for other
institutions as well. So where do we go with this, right?
So the routine inclusion of individuals and families of
diverse ancestries
has to be done, but something that we haven't really talked about is
that there are lots of reasons why this doesn't happen.
And so future research has to be
all inclusive, and of course, it has to be based on trust and partnership
with our study participants. And as we think
about our studies, it's important to think not just about
including
genetic ancestry differences, but non-genetic factors as well.
This I haven't touched on, but an area for future
conversations are that we can do things like use
mutation signatures of tumors
as biomarkers for individuals who share etiology
or that have functionally related tumor subtypes
or predispositions. And something else that
I think is really important is that we, and I think that this is something that
we'll hear about over the course of the next couple of talks, we
historically use global ancestry as a
biomarker for ancestry. And
in many studies, 80% of ancestry
X is thought of as the cutoff. So we
include individuals who are 80% or more African ancestry, for
example. We lump them together as African ancestry
individuals. Well, the problem, of course, is that
up to 20% of their ancestry is not, in
fact, African. And we have to think
about methods, and of course, there are methods that integrate
local ancestry as opposed to global ancestry in genetic studies
of diversity, and this is the future.
And so with that,
I will just remind you with the overarching
theme of our work, knowledge is power, right?
And thinking broadly and deeply engenders knowledge.
This is my lab from Chicago. This was our brief
foray into musical theater. Musical theater thanked us for
leaving,
and we've returned to science. And then this is just an
acknowledgment of all of the people who really did the work while I
get to stand here and tell you about it.
So with that, I'll stop. And I'm not sure if we have time for
questions, butIf there are
any, I'm happy to try to take one or two before we move on to the next talk.
Hi. Kim Rathmell, Ohio State. Thanks for that talk.
I wanted to ask specifically about the-
I'm sorry, I'm having trouble hearing you.
Oh, okay. Is it on now?
Mm-hmm.
Kim Rathmell from Ohio State. I had a question about the
model for your genetic medicine patient
management program. One, who are those doctors who are taking care of those
patients, and how do you
incorporate research into that, as well as algorithms for care?
And I'm thinking particularly, we're in a heme malignancy section about
BRCA mutations convey risk for heme malignancies, but those patients are often
in breast cancer genetic studies.
So how do you account for all of this new messiness that we're living in?
Right. So I just want to make sure I heard your question.
Yeah.
So the question has to do with the clinical genomics department.
How does that incorporate patients from across the institution-
Yeah
... coming from different places who might have different predispositions.
Yeah.
Is that right?
That's right.
Okay. So, it's actually incredibly simple.
What we do is we empower genetic testing across the
different departments, done at point of care,
and we make it so that every patient gets tested.
Right? And then the requirement is that any
patient who has a positive genetic finding gets
referred to clinical genomics, the medicine service.
But also because our colleagues aren't comfortable discussing
even things like variants of uncertain significance, which typically are
not used clinically. There are, of course, exceptions.
We see all of them as well. Okay? The
individuals who have true pathogenic variants come to see
us in the medicine service. The individuals who
have variants of uncertain significance are initially seen
by members of our counseling team, and then based
upon
their assessment of both the likelihood that a variant of
uncertain significance may or may not be pathogenic, and of
course, the family history as well, they either do or don't refer
them to clinical genomics, the medicine service, for ongoing
follow-up.
Great. Thank you.
Okay.
Hi. Tim Lei, WashU. Thanks, Ken. It's a really interesting
paradigm you set up here. One question, though, about race and ethnicity
and economic diversity. So a lot of these things are very
significant issues in terms of enrollment in studies like this.
Yeah.
A cancer center has to help.
I don't think you can do it alone.
Yeah.
But what kinds of programs are in place in your
cancer center to help include those diverse groups
and get them-
Right
... to participate in these trials?
Right. So that's an incredibly important question.
And that's why I actually highlighted the fact that as of right now,
over 80% of people who are approached to consent
are consenting.
So we seem to be succeeding.
Where we're sort of driving-
Why only 80%?
I'm sorry?
No, you're right. I'd love for it to be 100%.
Yeah.
The way that we're thinking about it...
So I have to also add that I've only been at Roswell
for less than two years, and these are all new programs.
So,
I don't believe that we have optimized things.
To be perfectly honest, we're still figuring it out.
Our legacy consenting process
has been human-based.
And we're converting to an e-consent process.
And
my hope is that that will help, but
it may not. It may actually have an
unanticipated negative effect on getting
people to consent. So I don't know the answer to that yet.
But in term-
Well, it's hard, but it's a worthwhile goal.
Say that again?
It's hard, but it's a worthwhile goal.
Well, that's right. And the idea is that by making
it available to everyone, our hypothesis is that, and
by doing things like having genetic testing performed
at points of care and consenting done at points of care,
we will just make it just part of the way we do business at Roswell
and make it available to everyone. But I don't know the answer to that yet.
Yes.
Thanks. So are you including heme malignancies in your
effort to be complete? And if you do, are you doing skin biopsies?
Are you waiting till they're in remission? How do you work them in?
This was a heme session, and that's really a challenge.
I'm sorry, I didn't hear your question.
Oh. Sorry.
And it's me. I apologize for that.
I'm sorrier.
So what do you do with patients with heme malignancies?
Are you including them in
your comprehensive approach?
Oh, 100%.
Are you doing their skin biopsies?
Are you-
Yeah
... doing them after they go into remission?
How are you-
Right
... systematizing this?
So it depends upon the patient.
We do remission samples. We do skin biopsies
on lots of patients who are coming to clinical genomics
early in their diagnosis. So it really is individually based,
but we have the capacity to do both.
Okay.
All right. Thank you very much.
And I will now turn the stage over
to Dr. Eisell with our next talk.
Thank you.
Thank you so much
for coming and for the great start into the session.
I think the build has been perfect and I'm really, really grateful for
ACR for providing this forum. Also, special extra thank you to
Wendy Kosan for putting the speakers and all of us in contact.
It has been really fun to do this. I'm going to, in this
presentation, talk mainly about acute myeloid leukemia,
showing some of our efforts, starting really with a level-setting first on
AML. We are all working in different fields.
Then about what's already known, and spend the last third of the
talk on unpublished data from multiple friends and
collaborators from across the country.
I have my disclosures.
So as a level setting in here, so AML
is classified as a disease, just as most of them,
just based on general histology, so the blast morphology associated
dysplasia. Then we're looking also at specific chromosomal
abnormalities. And then really more and more on the forefront are the
recurrent gene mutations
that are now disease-defining and that are also
prognosis-defining. This is an example of the European LeukemiaNet
classification. That is one clinically used
algorithm where we try to see which patients are more or less likely
to respond to, in this case, conventional cytotoxic chemotherapy.
And as you can see here, here are multiple different chromosomal aberration and
gene mutations in here, and generally patients who are
classified as favorable risk, say, for example, don't receive a stem cell
transplant in first complete remission.
I think it's good to remind ourselves how we come up with this, with the
disease classification, but even more so European LeukemiaNet or other
algorithms. The first thing that has to happen is that the patient has to
present to something as large as a comprehensive cancer center
that then enrolls this patient into biobanking and a clinical
trial, and this was just one of the excellent questions at the end, going through
the different filters. And this treatment site or the
biobanking site has to be so large enough that it contributes to
pivotal studies, and you have to have a PI
who has to be on one of these, either informing
sections and speaking up loud enough to actually put
these data and their samples into these studies that are being analyzed.
So a lot of patients are getting lost in this process.
The ELN and other genetic algorithms work for risk
prediction, and this is an example for AML if we classify it by
ELN risk. But I want to point out two different things here.
One thing is actually it's not really great that favorable prognosis
that we predict for a 60% survival.
This actually highlights how much room there is for improvement just in
general in AML to improve how patients are doing, but also
how we are predicting, which means there's a pretty big error rate and what is it
that we have to do to even make this error
prediction rate better. And the second thing I would like to point
out is if we use this, and these are very small studies, if we try to use these
algorithms on patients who are not of European ancestry, it
really becomes less distinct. And yes, it's on the one hand for numbers, and
on the other hand also highlighting that this might not be
usable across other populations.
Why could this be the case?
Everything that we know about AML is based on several very large-scale
studies. One of them,
the very first one being led by Violet Tingley in the audience and the
TCGA. We have now way over 4,000 AML patients,
but less than 2% are non-European.
And really pointing out that these patients were all basically treated at
major US cancer centers or European cancer centers,
so that there is very little diversity in anything that informs what
we are doing. So the central hypothesis is here
from my talk and what I really believe is that it's restricted view on AML
genomes, and thus the biology of AML impacts our
understanding of AML in general, because we just have been restricting
our knowledge pool in here. So we need to increase the size and diversity of the
patient populations. And while I'm focusing on genetic
ancestry in this talk,
this is not in isolation, as really Ken highlighted it out, but we have to
also put the lived experience geography into
consideration.
This is a good example, and it was very sobering for me.
This is just a molecular oncoprint done on data obtained from
Flatiron. And while they always have to be taken with a grain of salt, we spend
almost nine months, length of a pregnancy, to clean up this data
set from Flatiron, so I believe it had a good quality afterwards.
And the mutation frequency, the landscape that we see,
is very different. Flatiron has patients who are treated in the community,
and basically almost 60% of these patients would be
myelodysplasia-related in their classification.
Like everything is reversed in some parts, meaning that
the patients who have not been enrolled in here might have changed our
idea of what the most common, most frequent mutations in leukemia
are if we would have taken those into consideration.
So it means that we really have to look at this interaction of,
on the one hand, the genetics, so the ancestry as defined by ancestry informative
markers outlined before,
so the constitutional genetic background, and also race ethnicity, which I think
about as a lived experience, so everything else but shaping them in here.
And I will try to outline when I'm referring to what in here the
majority of studies will be
really defined by genetic ancestry.
So what do we know thus far how genetic ancestry
and/or race ethnicity matters in AML?
So there have been several studies who showed that
both in the setting ofJust general sciences like on
the SEER network, Black patients do significantly worse
than white patients. And this is also true if we look at patients who were treated
on the same frontline clinical trials of, in this case, the ALLIANCE
cooperative study group in here. And this has just been
shown not only in the setting of the ALLIANCE, but these are unpublished data
provided by Irum Khan and the group in ECOG-ACRIN, where also
Black self-reported race/ethnicity was the most important
factor for inferior overall survival.
And the survival disparity is not only seen in
older patients who may have a lot of comorbidities, it's actually especially
seen in young patients. That was shocking to me.
So if you look at somebody who's younger than 30 years of
age, and if this individual is Black,
there's an almost 12-year shorter overall survival in here,
median overall survival. And it's a combination of maybe a
delayed diagnosis. As you can see here, there are a lot of early deaths, but also a
very low complete remission rate,
highlighting that there's probably really a biologic rationale because all these
patients made it to a clinical trial.
They were all in the hospital, and they're still not responding to the treatment as
they should.
The third finding, and just as we all know, is
just highlighting and putting it in here is that, of course, the socioeconomic
factors impact on the survival. This is a study done by
Jesse Blassack, and Electa Paskett, where they use zip codes
as we can do it here, sadly, to assign a sociodemographic
index. And what you could see is that patients who have higher
social disparity index, they do poorly.
But the second thing on this side is that if you're Black
and have a high SDI index, you do even worse than white patients
in exactly the same sociodemographic group.
And, I think it's also notable to mention that there are,
unfortunately in the study, not enough Black individuals who are
classified as SDI low.
There are differences in the frequencies of the known genes
that we are testing every day in clinic.
And that's very important to denote, because we also know that
more patients are marker negative in here.
So for example, Black patients have almost 40% of the patient have a core binding
factor abnormality, where you would think this is supposed to be a favorable
risk feature.
But clearly, Black patients are still doing worse when they harbor this feature.
And what became really interesting is the more we talk with other
colleagues across the globe is
this is actually the breakdown pretty much everywhere else
except in patients of European ancestry.
So we are not looking at minorities here, but rather the other way around.
This is an example from patients from Africa showing also the low frequency of
NPM1 mutations in them. So it's not
only what we are seeing here in the US.
Next finding was that if we then do the effort and we
specifically sequence patients who are African American by
genotype-confirmed genetic ancestry,
we find new things.
There are at least 12 or 13 mutations that occur in a frequency
of 5% that are otherwise not seen at all in European
ancestry patients. That was done in comparison to Beat AML,
where we are glad to collaborate with Jeff Theiner and Shannon McVey
and his team on.
The other thing I wanted to point out down here are what we call marker
negative patients. These are whole exome sequencing studies.
So they had mutations, but they didn't have recurrent mutations, meaning, of
course, 100 patients are not enough to study, and I'm going to come back to this
later.
And then they have genes, and one is standing out here.
It's called PHIP,
that is especially mutated and that has not been seen at all in AML
patients before. That was recurrently mutated in 7%, and that was
validated in a Nigerian cohort of AML patients, but not found a
single time in patients from South Africa, meaning that there's
really an association that's more refined with respect to
geography. Also finding new gene fusions that are recurrent, haven't
been seen before, just for completion in here.
The second to last of the level-setting finding is that
interestingly, these recurrent mutations that we
are clinically using, they might have a very contrasting
impact. And I think the most outstanding example that we have here are the
mutations on the gene called NPM1, which confers a classic favorable risk
in AML. Patients do not get a transplant if they have this mutation,
except in some of the settings. But however, in patients who
are African American, it is the most adverse risk
predictor, with the highest relapse rates, like almost all
patients who harbor an NPM1 mutation will relapse.
So this is something to keep in mind, and I will go into more details on.
Similarly, IDH mutated patients do also very poorly
compared to their European ancestry counterparts.
And this is just, again, good when observations
validate data provided by Irum and from ECOG,
where they looked into their patients treated also on clinical front line trials
where patients who harbored an NPM1 mutations are doing poorly.
Why could this be the case? Of course, there are multiple reasons, but one of the
important studies done, and this was really led by Lee Grimes and his group
in Cincinnati, in collaboration, was to see if there's a
biologic reason for this. So we started by just total transcriptome
analysis, where you can see that African ancestry NPM1
mutated patients have a very different profile.
And if you just look here, at the PCA plot, there was one group that
was outstanding that I found especially curious, which was the white patients that
cluster with the Black
NPM1 mutated patients.And if you look how they're doing, it means
that the patients will have the same gene expression profile for whatever reason
they share the poor survival, meaning there's really something that's different in
here. And yes, they were genotype confirmed.
It was not that they had a more mixed ancestry
compared to other patients.
And if Lee performed a T-seq, which is a very comprehensive single-cell
profiling effort, while the majority of
the cellular aspect was identical, there were very distinct differences
in certain precursor populations, and also about NPM1 expression
by itself that was absent in MEP2 populations
of cells,
highlighting that there is an ancestry-associated difference in NPM1.
And if you try to look deeper and look at epigenetics associated with this, and
this is work done by Chris Oakes at Ohio State, he performed global
methylation profiling, where all the African ancestry patients have a
global hypermethylation if they have this feature.
And it seems to be associated with these differences in
immune response patterns, which makes sense in
multiple of the other studies that we are going to look at.
So where can we go from here?
I'm trying to break it down in a couple of different aspects, and
unfortunately, we do not have the time to go through all of them, so I tried to
pick a few highlights. I think the first step, if we find new
genes, always what we have to do is to define the clinical and biologic relevance.
But
what we can learn, I think, from every cancer genetics is that a gene doesn't
mutate just by itself, but it may be of relevance to the biology of the disease
and may have an associated pathway that hasn't been explored.
And so the idea is, even though we don't see these genes mutated
in other
race, ethnicity, or genetic ancestries, the gene might,
however, be of relevance.
And a great example here is this gene PHIP,
which
I by now strongly believe is an overlooked gene in myeloid diseases.
While it hasn't been reported before in AML, it's actually very common
in all the CH studies, one of the most commonly reported CH genes,
clonal hematopoiesis genes. However, it was believed that patients who
harbor PHIP variants will not progress, and
that is more considered a benign variation in here.
So could this differ in its progression with respect to genetic
ancestry?
So Lee Grimes and this fantastic postdoc, Bailey Cain, started to
do several different mouse models, and I don't go into their details, but
basically first seeing if you have a PHIP mutation, if it
would have a competitive advantage, yes or no, and indeed it has.
And then more importantly,
it seems to have a very strong leukemogenic potential, where they used a
background of a FLT3 model where they CRISPRed in the different
mutations that are seen in the
patients. And you can see that
the mice where we have the
PHIP mutation in here
die faster and have a more aggressive disease phenotype than those without.
The other part was to see, is there anything otherwise distinct?
So they
sequenced with a T-seq, again
the PHIP mutated patients and added some which are
wild type and came up with a very distinct gene expression profile.
And this is now very stunning to me.
So if you use this PHIP-associated profile, which we call
fitness,
other patients who do not have PHIP mutations with
diverse genetic ancestries, if you have a high
PHIP score or high fitness, you have a significantly worse
outcome. And this is refining really across all the ELN genetic
groups, thinking that it's very important to follow up on this gene and the pathway
for patients in general.
It is very important for us to consider external and internal stressors.
And as an example for that,
I want to point out the early onset myelodysplasia and
myelodysplasia phenotype that's seen in patients with African
ancestry. It's not more common to have AML-MR, but it comes at an
age of 14, 15, 16, 117 years.
So could this be the case that there's something
that leads to this early part? And these
patients do terrible. We know that having this myelodysplasia-related
AML is anyway an adverse prognosticator, but just look at the
survival of the patients with almost 95% relapse rate.
So if there's anything that triggers this, this is really something that we have to
try to prevent in the future.
And we see really high rates, and here I don't have a good comparator of clonal
hematopoiesis. How could we determine clonal hematopoiesis?
In our whole exome sequencing studies, we were using B and T cells that were
flow sorted from the
blood as a comparator, and we're then able to, by whole exome
sequencing, look at these mutational patterns.
And almost 15%, and we used a very high VAF cutoff in here,
had clonal hematopoiesis. And now it's a stunning aspect is that if
you have a clonal hematopoiesis in the setting of being African American, you
have an 80% relapse rate, even though usually the
persistent clonal hematopoiesis is not considered to be a risk factor.
So again, could there be a difference in external or internal
stressors that change our risk assessment for AML?
Because we know that
inflammation and stress in general is something that can lead to
progression in between the different disease stages
in here. And while the inflammation in AML has been shown to be
associated with certain oncogenic drivers, this is a great study from
Audrey Leslie and Bettina Nagel. Bettina actually also sits here in the back
from 2022.
This is something that can be modified, and that's not universally
associated with inflammation. And this is something I'm super excited about and
very grateful for Iram. We are collaborating on that.
She has an R1 on that, a study that she's doing to
look at social stress in the setting of preexisting clonal hematopoiesis
using the Chicago alliance of
AML providers in here. And
whatIrum is doing is that she's really modeling the effect of the social
stress on clonal hematopoiesis, especially on P53.
And what she can see in here is that there's a selective expansion of the P53
myeloid progenitors in vivo, and that it really promotes DNA
damage and enhanced proliferation in these mutant stem cells.
And they can link it together with the lived areas in
different Chicago areas, which of course, where we again have the
intersection of race, ethnicity, social constructs, and genetic
ancestry. But really exciting ongoing
work where I think this is exactly where it should be going, where we are looking
at a very select genotype
with consideration of all these other additional factors to better tease
out how we can think about this disease in a
different
fashion.
Then the last point, and this is my last part of the talk, is
of course, to sequence more patients and to collect more data.
And this is ongoing work of what we call ALL
AML project, together with
my friend, mentor, and partner in crime in here, Elaine Mardis, and my
great graduate student, Ethan Hamp, where we continue to do the
sequencing on African American and also
self-identified Hispanic patients, all treated with the same
chemotherapy, and grateful to collaborate with UPenn,
again, doing whole exome and RNA sequencing.
And this is the newest finding that came out of it.
And while we validated the genes that were recurrently mutated before, we
did one thing we didn't do, which was to look by gene families, because
sometimes one gene by itself doesn't have enough power.
And what you can see here when we look by gene families, there's one family that
has never been otherwise reported that's mutated at a frequency of
12%, which are our Rho
GTPases in here. Finally, at the same time, where we get the
results back, Omar Abdel-Wahab and his group published this paper where they had
looked at dependencies in hematopoietic stem cells, and this is a purely
CRISPR system, and where they happened to then introduce
the same mutations that we found in the patients.
They didn't see these mutations because they do not sequence
ARC mutations or ARC genes on their panel.
But thinking that there may be really something going on here, again, reaching out
then to Jeff Tyner and Beat AML, it seems to be more enriched in
European and African patients, and it seems to be enriched in patients who are
younger.
Talking to Jeff Cloke at
TARGET AML, it's not in pediatric patients, more enriched.
It seemed to be, if anything, more specific to the AYA component in
here, but otherwise not associated with adverse risk, which is
surprising,
because if it's more in a favorable risk, you would think that these patients do
well, but actually, they do terribly, more like adverse risk patients.
And having an ARC mutation in the setting of
favorable risk AML makes you do way worse
than what is expected from that.
In looking specifically in the AYA patients, you can see the very poor
disease-free event and overall survival of patients who harbor these mutations.
These are all GTPases, so they have to do with RAS signaling, although a
little bit lower. So what we are trying on the final stages of figuring out
is
how they additionally or activate the RAS pathway and how they can
cooperate with other RAS pathway mutations.
So in conclusion, we really need
to expand our genomic profiling efforts.
And maybe,
if I may say so, it is time to go beyond all these different
aspects into something like a TCGA 2.0.
Don't know, Tim, if you would be up for that, if there would be anything coming in
that really goes beyond everybody whom we have been sequencing
before. And I think there's a great community who would be in support
of that. And we learn way more, and I think it would be something very
worthwhile to do. And AML is always good to be all type A people
who treat AML patients, so we always like to lead the way in here.
If you want to read more, because these were just initial thoughts, I'm very
grateful to Blood Cancer Discovery,
and Tanja to allow Elaine and myself to write a little
in viewpoint that goes beyond what I showed just here, and
happy to discuss with all of you after.
There are so many people I have to thank as the collaboration across many
institutions, the United States and also Africa, where I really
want to highlight the support of the American Cancer Society.
Otherwise, it wouldn't be possible for us to do these kind of studies,
and other funders. So thank you.
We have time for one or two questions.
And thank you for resetting the time clock.
Hey, Kate. It's beautiful work. Thank you. Sobering.
A lot to think about. One thing you didn't mention was the genetic diversity in the
HLA locus and how that may be affecting some of these response rates.
Ability to respond to new antigens like nucleophosma may be very
different in these different populations and may have a huge impact on
response to therapy.
Yes. And it's ongoing. Elaine actually
ran it through her pipeline, she has this pipeline from breast
cancer part, and we did it on the first 100. Our numbers were not big enough.
Hopefully, they are now, but 100%, yes. I think that will be very fascinating.
Good.
Mm-hmm.
Hi. So before I ask my question, I just want to make a plug for the audience that
that perspective that Dr. Eisfeld wrote is really thought-provoking, and
everyone should look at it. But my question is about these
somatic mutations that are occurring with this sort of a unique frequency
in
ancestrally defined populations, and if there are any clues in there
about why these mutations are happening, clues about
different types of
low-level DNA repair or if there are any just signals
It's a very good question. I hope that we have a better answer just
because at the end,
at the moment, our cohort is not big enough.
Because I think it will be, there are some DDR and
damage repair signals that we saw, but I think what makes it
difficult to track it back is the high genetic
diversity, especially in African American patients.
So that's why we don't see them in here.
So I really think that this is what
muddies the water in some ways, so I think
my personal goal is to sequence 1,000 patients.
But again, how much is coming from ancestry versus
really how much of these genes would we find?
And I'm really fascinated by it, if we would just have sequenced the flat iron
patients. If we would go into the non-European, non-cancer center
parts in here, I don't know that, but I think we need to find that out.
And of course, this is where local ancestry methods will be very helpful.
Absolutely. Yeah.
Okay. All right, well, thank you very much. That was terrific.
And now, Dr. Penunsia, bring us home.
Well, it's really exciting to be here, and thank you for the invitation and for
this organization.
This is really a great set of talks so far, and I'm really excited to talk about
this project. It's really been a passion project of mine since I started my lab at
UCI in 2019.
Mostly because I feel like it has a really large impact on the community,
potentially, and also it's really pushed me to the kind of edge of my knowledge in
a lot of these different areas.
So what I'm really going to focus on here is a specific subtype of acute
lymphoblastic leukemia, PH-like ALL.
For those in the audience likely are familiar with this, this was a subtype that
was co-discovered by Charles Mulligan, who continues to work on this, as well as
several labs at MD Anderson and in Penn.
And essentially, it gets its name by the fact that it shares several of the same
characteristics as Ph-plus or Philadelphia chromosome-plus
ALL, but lacks that BCR-ABL1 chromosome.
And they're actually very genetically heterogeneous, but one thing that really ties
a lot of them together is that over 60% of them have overexpression of this
CRLF2, which encodes one half of this TSLP
receptor, which drives JAK-STAT pathway.
So one way this is actually diagnosed is by seeing excess CRLF2 on the cell
surface of these. So what's leading to this excess CRLF2
expression? It's actually one of two common
genome rearrangements. So one is a translocation with chromosome 14,
where a double-strand break is induced on the RAG complex during VDJ
recombination. And then another double-strand break is induced on the X
or Y chromosome with the CRLF2 locus.
And this puts the Mu enhancer in close proximity to CRLF2, leading to
overexpression. The other rearrangement is an interstitial deletion on the X
or Y chromosome, where two double-strand breaks near CRLF2 and
P2RY8 occur, leading to a deletion of the intervening sequence.
What's really interesting about these is that even though a large percentage have
these CRLF2 mutations, a lot of extra mutations are additionally
associated with this cancer, especially JAK2 mutations and other
mutations in IKZF1.
And what we've really found when we've studied this is that these PH-like ALLs
are very genetically unstable. So we've actually done long-read sequencing
on patients that have Ph-plus or PH-like, and remarkably from these Circos
plots, we can see that in the Ph-plus we see that
Philadelphia chromosome very clearly.
But in the PH-like, we see in addition to the CRLF2 rearrangement,
several other rearrangements and deletions throughout the genome, and you can
appreciate that too from these chromosome spreads.
So if you're familiar with this disease, you also likely know that it's associated
with a cancer disparity in people that identify as being Hispanic or
Latino. So this is a study from a cohort of patients at MD
Anderson, where they actually looked at the PH-like ALL and found that nearly
70% of the cases that they saw there are from
people that identify as Hispanic or Latino.
And if you look at those specifically, a large percent, almost 80%,
had this CRLF2 rearrangement. And so it seems that there's something about the
CRLF2 rearrangement that makes this a more aggressive treatment refractory cancer
and is also driving this health disparity in this Hispanic and Latino population.
So kind of really where I came into this is genome instability was kind of my
training and my background, and that's what my real interest was, trying to figure
out the etiology of this mechanism.
And just as a quick primer, just want to kind of go into some of the things that we
have found associated with this cancer.
But essentially, we knew one of the things that was happening was this
double-strand break on chromosome 14, but we're really interested in the CRLF2
double-strand break and what's causing that. Just want to skip ahead here.
A major clue from that came from work from Michael Lieber's lab, who did a lot of
work studying another translocation with IGH PCL2.
And what he found is that if you actually sequence the translocation junctions from
several of these different patients, shown here as these triangles,
at PCL2, they seem to cluster in very tight regions.
And they all seem to cluster around these CpG sites.
And so what's significant about that is that these CpG sites are actually motifs
that are recognized by activation-induced cytidine deaminase, which is one of the
common motifs
other than WGCW sites. And while you're likely familiar with AID
as being common in germinal centers, where it's highly expressed to drive
somatic hypermutation and class switch recombination, there is evidence showing
that it can have leaky expression in immature B cells concurrent with VDJ
recombination. And they've done some really interesting work to kind of show that
this is the etiology of that translocation.
And so kind of going back to the model that we're putting forth, we wanted to test
to see if a similar thing was happening with CRLF2 IGH
translocations. Where in normal B cells, we would have the RAG complex
leading to VDJ and CRLF2 is unperturbed.
Whereas in this state here you would have sporadic AID expression leading
to additional breaks at CRLF2 driving this
rearrangement.And so in order
to delve into this, what we actually did was we developed an innovative digital
PCR assay to actually interrogate the sequences of
CRLF2. And we can do this both in cell lines and in
human patients, which is shown in this study shown here.
But just to kind of briefly overview this, if you're not familiar with this assay,
essentially what it allows you to do is to take one PCR and convert it into
20,000 individual PCRs, where we can quantitate genomic changes
through fluorescent probes. And what I'm showing here is the CRLF2 locus.
And CRLF2 has three of these
CpG sites that can be recognized by AID, which are underlined in red.
And we essentially just designed a probe, FAM, TAMRA, and Cy5 to sit on top of
these. And essentially what would happen is if AID is acting at these sites, it
would mutate that site, the probe can no longer bind, and we can actually quantify
what's happening at that locus.
And so what we did was we had a dox-inducible AID system integrated into
our Nalm6 cells to actually see that this is actually the case.
So remarkably, what we can see is that whether we have increasing
expression of AID or prolonged exposure to AID, these
sites are in fact being mutated. And what we can see here is that the
TAMRA and the FAM sites seem to be much more highly affected than
the Cy5 site,
giving us a real solid clue that AID is a major driver for a lot of
these
translocations.
But of course, that doesn't really get to the heart of the disparity issue.
And for that, what we really have to do is turn to
actually further examining a lot more PH-like ALL samples.
So it is a rare cancer, but several study sites, particularly at MD
Anderson and St. Jude, have collected quite a bit of these.
But at UCI, we kind of have a unique catchment area in Orange County, which is
just north of here, where we have a predominantly Hispanic and Latino
population. And so what we really wanted to do was collect a lot of these
patient samples from the community and actually sequence them and try and
understand a little bit better if we can
know what's leading to this disparity.
And so this is a collaborative work at UCI with Angela Fleishman and Fabiola
Quintero-Rivera, and we've also reached out to Linda Bond at the Mayo Clinic to get
additional samples.
What I really want to point out with this slide, though, is this last column.
So what I'm showing here is essentially self-identified race or ethnicity, which we
have available for several of our studies at UCI.
But there's two problems with this column.
So one problem is, as has been kind of discussed here, there's a
difference between self-identified race and ethnicity and genetic ancestry.
And really it's been commonly shown that while there's social and economic factors
associated with race and ethnicity, there's no real biology there
associated with genetics. And so for that reason, we really need a genetic
ancestry
to weigh to study a lot of these populations.
And the second issue you can see is that several of these are unknown or not
reported.
So again, we're kind of not being able to really pick out a lot of the high-risk
patients here from the self-identified race and ethnicity.
And so this is a very common problem.
And even in the TCGA, which has been an amazing
resource, we can see that even within this database, there are
populations that are marked down as unknown.
And what this really creates is an issue, because if we could actually unlock the
genetic ancestry of some of these unknown or unreported ancestries,
we might actually be able to better understand a lot of the
disparities, not only in PH-like ALL, but several other types of cancers.
And so that was really the driving force behind this collaborative project
that we have at UCI, which is a collaboration between Salma
Masri, Marcus Selden, and is really driven by these two graduate students,
Angie Nguyen and Shannon Pfeiffer, who are fully computational in our labs and have
really delved into trying to understand this ancestry problem.
And essentially what we wanted to do was kind of go out and see in terms
of what's out there publicly available that we can use as
data to generate kind of an algorithm where we could plug in our whole genome
sequencing, our whole exome sequencing data, to essentially
reveal the genetic ancestry of the patients that we're seeing.
And one thing that we kind of ran into immediately with that is that some of
the publicly available data that's out there is very
heterogeneous. And so what I'm showing here is data from the Genome
Aggregation Database or gNOMAD, and this is from their build that used 1,000
genomes in the Human Genome Diversity project.
So we haven't seen any of these yet, but these are admixture plots.
And if you're unfamiliar with them, essentially within each of these vertical lines
is an individual person. And the colors indicate
essentially the genetic similarity they have to six major
population groups that we have outlined here.
And you can see in the gNOMAD cohorts, it kind of has a span from ones
that identify kind of more fully as this admixed American group to
ones that are much more heterogeneous with much more European and African ancestry.
So what we really wanted to do is we kind of just went into the field in EGA and
dbGaP to try and find as many of these cohorts that
are from different regions in Central and South America to really try
and add to this power of this study to kind of build out this
algorithm for
looking at
genetic ancestry so we can classify them.
And so admixed American is one population that was sort of underrepresented with
the available data out there.
And another one that we're really excited about is the Middle Eastern North African
population. And so there were some gNOMAD cohorts that were available to
that. But this is really a group that's underrepresented in a lot of genomic
studies, particularly in the US where this isn't
always an option to choose from on a lot of intake forms for
studies. And so a lot of people that are Middle Eastern, North African
get binned into different categories because they don't necessarily have a
way to identify themselves by race and ethnicity.
And we've actually been able to find a number of publicly available studies from
regions throughout the Middle East and North Africa to sort of add to this study
here.And what essentially that turns out to looking into is
that we take all the data that we've aggregated together and can do an
unsupervised admix analysis. So essentially that means we're not forcing the
data into any certain spot. We're just telling it to bin all of these the best
you can into six of these different categories And what we actually found was
that, there's very good correlations for the East Asian, European, and African
populations here, and Central South Asian.
But the added cohorts we can appreciate from the admixed American group
is that, we kind of see here a dichotomy between ones that
have much more of this admixed population, which are likely more
identifying and genetically similar to Central and South
America,
and a more heterogeneous, truly admixed American population here with different
populations.
And remarkably too, we can actually see that there's a good representation of the
Middle Eastern North African population.
And we can actually see that this genetic similarity is present in some of the
European, South Central Asian, and admixed populations, too.
And what's really remarkable about this, if you think about it, these are
populations that were always part of these large genomic studies
but were largely invisible because we didn't have a way to deaggregate them
from a lot of the other genomic studies.
And so one thing that we're really excited about now is actually looking at this
population and actually uncovering more disparities in this population with the
ability to look at this ancestry.
And just to kind of emphasize this point more, these are PCA plots.
These are actually pruned PCA plots.
If they weren't pruned, you would actually see that this admixed American
population would stretch from the corner here all the way into this population just
because they're so very admixed here.
But I really want to emphasize is that these added cohorts that we have have really
clustered
a lot of this population here, so we're truly kind of looking at much more
of a potential Central South American population rather than this highly
admixed group.
In addition to that, the clusters of MENA that we've added have added very nicely
to what's known already out there in gnomAD.
So what does this mean if we essentially go back and look at some of the whole
exome sequencing data or sequencing data in a data set like TCGA?
So currently, what our build has is the ability to assess nearly
60,000 different SNPs if we have whole-genome sequencing data or around
15,000 different SNPs if we have whole exome sequencing data.
And we can appreciate here is that within this population that identified as
white, there's actually a significant proportion that have this MENA signature
of admixture. And if we look at the populations that
identified as Hispanic or Latino, we can kind of see that there's a large mix here,
where a lot of the unknown and white definitely have this potential admixed
American signature, whereas some of the other people that identified as Hispanic or
Latino have signatures that kind of vary quite greatly.
So I really feel like this is going to be a really amazing tool for us to be able
to use to look at a lot of these large genomic data sets, tease out a lot of
genetic ancestry
data and really give us a much more granular view of these different
populations.
Okay. So that was kind of a segue, but kind of getting back to what that means for
a PH-like ALL. Well, essentially now we can take all those patients that were in
that table we had and now assign them genetic ancestry based on this
algorithm. And of course, as we mentioned before, no one is like essentially
one population. But what these admixture plots allow us to appreciate is that all
of these people have a mixture of a lot of these different ancestry groups that are
binned here. And one thing that really stood out is, of course, because there is
this disparity with PH-like ALL, it's not surprising that we see that a
large amount of this admixed American, where people that identify as Hispanic or
Latino would be. But what is interesting is that we kind of see a split in a
lot of these different categories, both in the CRLF2-IGH and
P2RY8, where there is this more increased mix of European,
but also this MENA signature that we've started to develop as well.
So how can we actually apply this to some of our data, and what might
be causing the etiology of some of these PH-like ALL cases?
As I mentioned in the beginning of the talk, JAK2 is a mutation that commonly
occurs, and it's usually correlated if you have CRLF2 overexpression
already. And this is actually a different JAK2 mutation that is
present, in say, MPN. So this usually affects this
arginine 683, turning it to a glycine or a serine.
But what we can actually do for all the patient material that we collect is we can
actually go back to our dPCR assay, because dPCR is
really good at looking at specific alleles, and the presence and
quantifying the amount that's there.
And we can actually use this assay to detect what patients actually have the
JAK2 mutation if it wasn't already reported by them.
And what was really striking is when we overlaid that with our ancestry data,
obviously this is underpowered, and we need to
generate many more of these samples and collect more samples.
But we see the R683G mutation seems to at
least trend towards associating with CRLF2-IGH
translocations, particularly those that have a mixture of this European and MENA
population. So I think what this really shows is that looking
at ancestry has the potential to reveal a lot more about what could be happening in
the etiology of this disease and also potentially giving more treatment
options of populations that might need more treatment with, say,
TKI inhibitors or JAK2 inhibitors.
So just to conclude here, some of our future directions are to
continue to use ancestry data to inform translocation mechanism.
So we've already started doing this with a lot of the sequencing we already have,
and we've actually identified that a lot of mutations that are
classified as variants of uncertain significance may actually be
present in this admixed American population and driving this cancer, particularly
some mutations that we found in the gene ARTEMIS, which is really critical for VJ
recombination. Continue to do TPCR diagnostics to monitor
mutations, and essentially determining ancestry from a lot of these other
genomic data sets, because I feel like this would be a really useful tool
mixed in with a lot of the other
factors that we've heard here today in terms of environment and lifestyle to really
kind of at least get a better view of when we're talking about disparities, which
populations we're actually talking about.
And because heme malignancies was in the title of the talk, I also include some of
the data from AML and DLBCL that we applied to
from some of the TCGA
analysis.So I just want to
thank my lab and everyone that did the work there, and my collaborators at UCI,
Salma, Marcus, and also Linda Bonn at the Mayo Clinic,
and of course, all the patients that consented to have their material analyzed for
these. So thank you very much for your time.
Before turning to the general discussion, we have time for a couple of
questions.
I'll ask the first one then.
Okay.
So if we think about the Middle Eastern, North African population, do you
know where Ashkenazi and Sephardi Jews fall?
So actually, the nomad cohort was all from sites throughout Israel.
So that could be that's where they are.
But I know that
Mike Berger has actually done some studies where they've actually looked at that
population more specifically.
And are they clustering in terms of etiology with Arab
populations? Do you have any information?
So I know the ones that were collected throughout Israel, they seem to cluster
pretty well since those were the nomad ones.
Right.
The Ashkenazi Jew we haven't put in exactly where they cluster with that.
But I'd imagine they would likely, too.
Yeah. Thank you.
Hi there. Enjoyed the talk.
I'm really fascinated by this idea that, if I understand the
last piece there of the presentation, you've got these two somatic JAK mutations.
And one of them is clearly more associated with one set of
SNPs than another set of SNPs, and those SNPs are associated with this genetic
ancestry.
Right.
I'm wondering if you've thought about what the mechanism
behind that sort of bias might be,
and
if you've got any evidence or just what your spitball
theories are. It's fascinating to me.
Yeah, I agree, and as someone that has always studied DNA repair, it's like, why at
that particular site in these patients?
And I think what it's really going to take is just a much broader view of what all
the SNPs are that are contributing to potential genome instability at
these sites. So I think that's one reason we just want to keep collecting a lot of
this data and better understand what would be happening
there. But it'd be great if we can essentially do a functional
assay. So one aspect in our lab, what we're actually trying to do is try to take
material from a patient, derive iPSCs from that, and actually
derive their entire bone marrow organoid component.
So we can actually look at certain differences in that population and see if we
take one from one of those populations that had the CRULF2 IGH, can we
actually see those JAK2 mutations going up?
And maybe then we can infer a mechanism of how it's happening.
That's great. Thank you.
Mm-hmm.
And then just one more question.
Co-mutations as a function of these ancestries in
admixed populations. What are you seeing?
In terms of-
Somatic
... well, yeah. I think the IKFZ1 we haven't really looked at, but I think that one
occurs in several of these, and I think that might be driving a lot of the RAG
expression-
Yeah
... which could be leading to some of the
off-target RAG effects there.
Right.
But we haven't looked specifically at the correlation there
for these different populations.
But I think this is still unpublished data, and we're still working on building the
algorithm. So I think those are really exciting questions that we want to ask.
One more question, Ken.
Go ahead.
All great talks, and thanks, Nick. That was so good.
So admixed Latino populations
are generally thought of to be the
American Indian, Asian, Mongolian component, right?
That came
across the Bering Strait plus Europeans, right?
Have you looked at that at all? Because you know in diabetes, it
was found that the Denisovan,
thought to be the migration, is what
is
associated with the really high rates of diabetes in both American
Indians and Latinos. And so I didn't know if you could
separate that part of the ad-
That's essentially the goal, what we want to do with, say, looking at these
populations here. So, just because it's not published yet, I don't have them, but
it's very clear that I can say for sure that this is the Puerto Rican
population here. These are Mexican Americans in LA that were collected from
there. And so in these populations here, there's clearly a spectrum here where
we could see maybe that more indigenous Native American population.
And so I think really we could just apply those questions using this ancestry
information and see where in the spectrum a lot of those patients lie.
So if we could sequence them and determine their ancestry and see what their
admixture looks like, it might help pinpoint that.
Is there a known disparity with American Indians? Just curious.
Has anybody-
There is actually one for Artemis SKID.
No kidding.
And so since Artemis is really heavily involved in VJ
recombination and likely these translocations- ...
we think that there actually could be a correlation between that population and
this disparity.
Great. I mean, not great, but interesting.
No, thanks.
Thank you.
Okay. Thank you very much, Dr. Pannunzio. That was fantastic.
We have five minutes left for general discussion,
if there are thoughts or comments from the audience or from
my fellow speakers.
Or we can discuss right here.
Right. Or we can just meet out front.
We can do those, too. I have one question for you, Ken.
I meant to ask, what is the panel you're using for NGS testing?
Is it in-house, send out, same across
solid and liquid?
Right. So that's a super important question, and of course, it differs
for both germline and tumor, right?
The goal where we're moving towards is paired tumor
normal whole genome sequencing plus whole transcriptome sequencing.
We're not there yet. We're leveraging clinical
sequencing as the driver for generating our
biobank. And so for the germline
part, right now we're using Ambry panels
for our solid tumors and Invitae panels, a
combination of leukemia, MDS, bone marrow
failure, and these sorts of panels for our liquid
tumors. And as someone had asked earlier, we're trying
to use specifically
skin biopsies as our source, but as appropriate, depending upon
the patient, we are using remission samples as
well.And then, of course, the tumors are a whole
exome, largely.
All right.
I was actually wondering, I really like the system you've built at Roswell
Park for consent and NGS. And
I'm wondering if that was something that you started when you got there, because I
would really love to see that
even at UCI, obviously. And I think we have a consent now, but I think
I could see that there could be some pushback for paying for NGS for all of these
patients, and I wonder how you overcome that.
Yeah. So that's a super important question.
And it's part and parcel with the way that we're thinking about doing this.
So first is universal consent, having
access to samples, data,
serial samples, and
right to recontact. Being able to think of
our partners in research as,
I really like to think of them as a living biobank.
And that's a wonderful metaphor, and going on journeys of discovery
together are concepts that really do
resonate with our patients. In terms of
pushback, you're right. We speak to
our clinicians in different areas, and their
question is, "Why are we doing this?" Now, of course, the answer
is because if you don't look, you don't find.
And what we know from germline testing through,
really, most prominently, a study by Mary-Claire King that was
published in, I think it was "JAMA Oncology"
in either 2014 or 2017. She took
1,000 Ashkenazi Jews, offered them germline
genetic panel testing,
identified the 15% to 20% that you would expect that have some
sort of inherited predisposition, but then she binned that 15% to
20% between those that met criteria for testing and
those that didn't meet criteria for testing, and it turned out to be a coin flip.
So in fact, that is really important.
What we think the absence of red flags,
if you will, for germline predispositions is more
akin to no information than to no family
history. People die for lots of reasons.
If you get hit by a truck at 30, you're not going to get cancer at 50.
Our parents' generation, cancer was a
dirty word. There are all sorts of reasons for negative
red flags, negative criteria. And now in the modern era,
knowing germline predispositions in particular matter
for clinical decision-making. And so putting together
the Mary-Claire King paper and the fact that this
matters for how our doctors are treating, actually has
helped move the needle in the very short time that I've been there to
get
buy-in for this work. But it wasn't something that just
happened when I got there.
Yeah.
All right. And with that, let's conclude the session.
Thanks, everyone. This was really wonderful, and we
appreciate your interest. So thank you.
Thanks for chairing.
I think it was a good flow.
I think it was a good flow from
exactly
that.